giannis pappas
keep it going for the hilarious andrew
schultz
new york shady how the [ __ ] you doing
new york
that's not really the accident anymore
isn't it it's more like in new york city
party
get a couple smoothies
it's the best city that's why everyone
comes here i mean let's be honest other
cities are a little jealous
you know especially boston you ever
notice boston [ __ ] hates new york
you know what the funny thing is we're
not thinking about them at all
ever you know yeah
boston treats new york like we used to
date way back in the day
you know and we moved on with our lives
and became somebody and they're just
[ __ ] stalking our facebook page
you [ __ ] cork sucker
it's like boston let it go dude we are
way out of your league all right
go date philadelphia you got a lot in
common
this is how you can tell boston's a
shitty city
because you ever notice every movie
about boston is about some guy trying to
get out of boston
it's like well if i see you here in the
morning i will [ __ ] kill you myself
you go [ __ ] make something to
yourself kid you're not gonna just hang
around here wearing construction boots
in a car
ben affleck sitting by a riverbank
finally found serenity
with a hipster beard i give them credit
they love their teams they got a lot of
pride they just take it a little too far
you know
i shot my half-hour special there and i
came i was wearing a yankee hat they
treated me like i was wearing an isis
t-shirt or something you know like
i said slow it down it's just a baseball
team i like you know
it's like i'm a yankee fan i get it i'm
a hardcore yankee fan but like i don't
wear yankees pajamas to bed every night
you know if the yankees don't win i'll
be all right there's stuff to do here
not like boston red sox lose the crime
rate shoots up 15 percent
people start hitting their [ __ ]
family members
the cops show up like what's going on
here it's like well officer the [ __ ]
red sox lost
he's like all right keep hitting them i
understand [ __ ]
[ __ ] socks [ __ ] socks
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild